you work with the cartels to cross the
border illegally because the cartels
control the entirety of the Southern
border yeah opposite and the cartels run
rampant within the countries as well so
if you're trying to escape the cartel
and the only way you can do you don't
escape it by Crossing illegally across
that border you have to work with the
cartels to cross illegally across do you
think every illegal immigrant is working
with the cartel yes practically speaking
yes the cartel's control the entirety of
the Southern border and so what they do
is they P off the cartels and then they
end up in a type of SL after they after
they cross over do you think that
they're still working with the cartel or
do they work with the they owe them a
lot of money they owe them a lot all the
illegal immigrants owe them a lot of
money and they're working with the
cartel yeah they they can you
substantiate that I can't that that's
how they end up in prostitution which
was how we got on this topic because of
modern-day sex slavery or they end up
running drugs or they end up in other
criminal Enterprises for the cartel well
first first who do you think controls
the Border